[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you just tapped into the new season of
the group chat live in the bleacher
report app presented by fanduel i'm greg
ivory alongside the lovely aaron dolan
aaron are you ready for nba to be back
yes i am so excited for nba to be back
i'm so excited to be on my second season
of the group chat so let's get right to
it
yes ma'am let's get right to it we're
giving away hoodies we're giving away
jerseys matter of fact
the first one is going out now i'm about
to hook someone up in the chat with 125
to buy whatever jersey they want aaron
know about the handy dandy ipad but i
have his little cousin today the handy
dandy phone this right here is how
you're going to get your hoodie this is
how you're going to get your jerseys so
uh let me tap in let me tap in i see
sammy sammy 94. sammy 94 says uh
says 37 points he'll score 37 points
talking about lebron seeing that
lebron's gonna score 37. uh i have one
more one more i have carla ken 30 says
lebron's going to score 30 points shout
out to you charlotte can 30 you are
walking away with the jersey gift card
uh i'm not only hooking one person up
fanduel is also plugging everybody
they're plugging us and we have aaron
aaron is the fanduel plug everybody if
you don't know now you know aaron tell
them what's the deal
so in honor of the nba's 75th season
vandals giving new customers 75-1 odds
on any team to win their first game
today or tomorrow max bet is two dollars
while you might think oh that's super
low at 75-1 odds that's the chance to
win up to 150 so you can place a lot of
bets with that money
yes yes yes you definitely can place a
lot of bets with that money uh fanduel
is also running back our favorite bet
airing the three by two for both games
tonight the question is though will
there be two three pointers in the first
three minutes of the game that is what
the three by two is we asked you on
twitter which three by two will cash
tonight is it milwaukee versus brooklyn
or the warriors taking on the lakers we
did a twitter poll and these are the
results the results are
right there as you can see the warriors
are in front at 62 percent uh aaron
milwaukee in brooklyn at 38
uh looks like this golden state laker
game is gonna run away would it uh i
need you guys to get in the comments and
tell me which 3x2 is a lot tonight get
creative i need gifts i need emojis and
most importantly most importantly i need
winners only please aaron talk to us
what is your take on the three by two
tonight
well i love that we brought back the
three by two i'm gonna ride with the
nets and bucks i mean have you seen
giannis draining those threes in the
preseason we know kd and company can
also drain those threes as well now
remember last season i like to bring up
a couple of the stats so i found one
that was kind of interesting in terms of
three by two so the league-wide
three-point rate has increased in each
of the last 10 seasons up to an average
of 39 last season it's increased more in
the last five years than it did in the
previous five and get this last season
28 out of the 30 teams took at least one
third of their shots from three-point
rage so i'm riding with the nets and the
bucks greg i assume you're rocking with
your own favorite team
aaron you already know the deal you know
the deal but before i get into my take
let me hop into these comments uh i see
enderman enderman has steph curry
shimmying as a gift shout out to you
enderman you are walking away with the
hoodie um i got chris
chrisj2173 says warriors lakers shout
out to you chris j you are walking away
with a hoodie uh brandon brandon b nod
brandon b nod says warriors lakers will
win that aaron i have to make my
decision i am a man of the people the
people have spoken i just read three
comments that is leaning towards this
golden state warriors uh lakers game
and it's plus money i mean come on i'm
riding with my guys i'm riding with the
warriors right with the lakers there are
shooters all over the court lakers got a
team full of hall of famers and the
warriors we know what they do they put
up shots and this year they're gonna put
up the most threes i'm i'm calling it
right now they're gonna put up the most
threes in franchise history this year uh
here we go
i believe we're riding as a family aaron
the producer just told me in my ear we
were riding as a family with the golden
state warriors and the lakers three by
two and guess what aaron i'll be at the
game tonight with my man met up on our
test so tap into the ig story where you
guys were jealous the kid met her
we got to get right to one of these
games one of these days
we gotta get you let's do a show one of
these days we're gonna do a show at one
of these games but moving on aaron
how many points will lebron james score
we asked you in the app how many points
will lebron score tonight against the
warriors
there it is uh get in the comments and
tell me how many points lebron is
putting up and at the end of the game
will dm one person who gets closest and
hook you up with the jersey aaron lebron
is sitting at i believe 23 and a half
points the line is moving up and down
do you like that number
so lebron averaged 25 points per game
last season with this number set at 23
and a half it keeps coming down
yesterday it was at 24 and a half i'm
still gonna go with the under he's going
to be distributing that ball plus i want
to see how this big three plays together
i don't like to put too much weight into
the preseason he did hit over this
number in the last game 30 points in 29
minutes and a loss to the kings but
against the warriors and it's a regular
season game it's also opening night i
think it would be a little bit different
and i'm still unfortunately i'm gonna go
with the under i know you don't feel the
same greg
oh aaron before i hop into it before i
hop into it i have to talk to the people
because they can probably persuade me to
go the other way i'm in comments and i
see jay winters 84 says lebron's going
for 33 tonight so he's rocking with the
over shout out to you jay winters 84 you
are rocking away walking away not riding
but walking away with a hoodie i'm
moving on i see
i see uh i see aaron cool aaron cool is
in the comments shout out to you aaron
cool i want to be as cool as you but he
says lebron's going for 31 points 31
points tonight okay once again rocking
with the over aaron uh i got one more
hoodie in me i got one more hoodie in me
i see ryan ray ryan ray says 25. aaron
unfortunately that is the over and i am
riding with the fans i'm writing with
the people in the comments i am gonna
lean lebron james over here
now that doesn't mean
i think that they're gonna win the game
aaron there's no there's no hard feeling
like i just i just feel like
it's gonna come out tonight i just feel
like lebron's gonna come out tonight and
try to put the ball in the basket we
know this lakers team is going to
facilitate the ball they have rust he's
a natural facilitator they have braun
he's a natural facilitator they have
rondo that's what rondo does we know
they're going to facilitate but they
need
people to put the ball in the basket and
i feel like lebron knows that so with
that being said lebron's gonna try to
come out aggressive tonight
but that does not mean they're gonna win
um
remember please remember we're gonna hit
one of you guys up after the game and
hook you guys up with the jersey but i
got more jerseys to give away right now
so let's get to this next segment aaron
we talk warriors lakers now let's talk
nets bugs who are kicking off the season
with the rematch of last year's eastern
conference semi-finals which i don't
need to remind you was a seven game
battle tonight we want to know who you
think is scoring more points is it
giannis or is it katie get in the
comments tell me who you think is going
off aaron
which way are you leaning
so i think kd will have more points in
giannis we know this is a revenge game
after losing that game seven it was
tragic for them katie actually averaged
35 points 10 rebounds five assists in 42
minutes during that semi-finals then on
the other side the ball giannis he's the
only player to have averaged at least 25
points per game on true shooting
percentage of 60 or better in each of
the last three seasons so it's kind of
easy to say yeah giannis is going to
come out be able to hit that but i mean
kd is kd
he's playing with a chip on his shoulder
i'm definitely taking him over giannis
tonight
aaron is rocking with k.d aaron is
rocking with katie all right aaron you
have spoken let me see what the people
on the handy dandy iphone is talking
about i see a lot of people rocking with
kd in the comments i got sports feed
says 38 points katie leads the game and
he's got a kd gif of him jumping around
i got raider909 saying kd all day shout
out to you raider909 oh
i got j23 cash says giannis for sure
shout out to you j23 cash joe gan is in
the building rocking with giannis shout
out to everybody that i just mentioned
everybody that has just mentioned you
are walking away with the hoodie let me
hop in here aaron
i'm rocking with you i'm riding with you
i think kd is going to come back today
and he has a chip on his shoulder i
mentioned that was a battle last year uh
the nets went into the playoffs a little
beat up and you know
it it
it it hurted them in the end i mean this
bucks team ended up beating that next
team and i think kb is going to come
back with a little vengeance and a chip
on his shoulder tonight and he might go
for 50 aaron he might just might go for
50. he
i mean nothing surprises me with kd
yeah i mean it's it's it's kevin durant
like like he said aaron you know who i
am i mean we know who he is he's kevin
durant let's move on we talked tonight's
game now let's talk futures i want you
i want to know actually aaron i want to
know who do you think is winning it also
get in the comments and drop your locks
because i'm going to give away a jersey
to my favorite take uh let's take a look
at the odds aaron tell me what do you
see here
yeah so the brooklyn nets are the
favorite plus 250 lakers behind plus 400
the lakers are actually accounting for
37 percent of the money to win outright
on the fanduel sports book nets are
behind them at 14
in terms of money just the top five
teams i wanted to mention before we get
into my pick nets lakers your warriors
bulls and 76ers to round out the top
five in this market if i had to choose
i'm gonna go with the long shot just
because it is a long season i like the
miami heat 25 to one now i know they
were swept by the bucks this year in the
playoffs but kyle lowry jimmy buckets
tyler hero victor oladipo bamana bio pj
tucker i mean 25 to 1 go with the long
shot in this market and i'd like them to
come out of the east
okay erin has just dropped her pick but
erin i have to know are you sprinkling
some money on your sixers this year
the only sprinkling i feel at this point
i'm going to be doing is more vodka into
my drink the more i hear about ben
simmons and his drama as we know the man
got kicked out of practice today as he
should have for his poor attitude i
think this is absolutely going to affect
the chemistry on the team and just
personally i'm not going to be
sprinkling any money on the 76ers until
i see them play without ben on the floor
aaron is not a fan of ben simmons but uh
i'm not a fan that is oh i think that's
not a segment on this
[Laughter]
there's not a fan but that is okay
because i am a fan of giving you guys
hoodies so i'm in the comments right now
reading some of you guys takes i got a
i have
vr bedding is in the comments shout out
to br betting in the comments i have
um
snoopy 2153 says celtics wow and celtic
celtics after big mid mid-season
acquisitions a lot of fiery emojis shout
out to you snoopy 2153 i like the
curveball there you are walking away
with the hoodie um i'm also giving away
a jersey here aaron so if you hear me
say a comment and you feel like it's
jersey worth just let me know and i'll
give that person a jersey okay i have
dubs and jordan pool wins 2022 finals
mvp chandler whoop whoa whoa whoa whoa
slow the brakes i am a dubs fan but
that's that that's a little that's a
little aggressive there but shout out to
you chandler you can walk away with a
hoodie for your aggressive take i'm
still in the comments i'm still in the
comments i have julio hernandez here he
writes to both of us aaron he said hey
aaron and greg the lakers will want it
all multiple hall of famers no drama and
when you have lebron and the healthy ad
it's going to be tough to overcome with
all those pieces that they have added
shout outs
that's the great ques that's a big
question can they stay healthy aaron in
fact i feel like julio he wrote to both
of us and he gave us a detailed take
julio you are walking away with the
jersey brother you were watching crazy
with a jersey shout out to you uh aaron
let's move on let's talk mvp let's talk
mvp let's put those odds
let's put those odds up please can we
put those odds up for the mvp
so there we it they're in favor right
now plus 500 what do you see
what do you see what do you sell do you
see anything anything catches your eye
luca being the most bet on player in
this market on the fanduel sports book
obviously sticks out to me the last
three guards to win mvp were hard in
westbrook and curry who all averaged 30
points per game last season as we know
nicole yokic was able to win it he
played a mort excuse me he played more
time than let's say a dwell embiid and
kevin durant so he's able to get that
and he's actually a long shot on the
board right now so in this market again
you could take a long shot because so
many things can happen especially with
some players sitting on back to backs
and health and availability
yes yes yes yes yes um
i think if i was gonna
yeah who who wait who are you who you
gonna ride with and who are you gonna
ride with
so if i was gonna rock with somebody in
this market i think i'm gonna go with
damian lillard 12-1 right now to win
this i mean he's averaged 29 points last
season he's obviously one of the biggest
pieces of that team i mean there is of
course a case you can make for giannis
two-time mvp reigning finals mvp
averaged 28 points per game over the
last three seasons and now he's working
on his jumper of course we could talk
about kd as well but i think in this
market like i said taking that long shot
aaron's rocking with lillard no giannis
no doncic no kd she's rocking with
lindler
let me get into these comments i got to
see who they're rocking with i got to
see who the people in the comments oh i
see embiid the real t smith says this
might be in beads here shout out to you
the realty smith you are walking away
with the hoodie i got z buddy in the
comments says lebron mvp lebron mvp
shout out to you z buddy you were
walking away with a hoodie aaron this
one caught my attention noah j rodriguez
says curry going crazy this season lock
and i'm going to stop right now shout
out to you noah you were walking away
with the hoodie yes i love that steph
curry he should have won the mvp last
year the warriors got better this year
clay's coming back no i think especially
with those scoring titles and everything
if he goes off and has an unbelievable
season i mean in pre-season he was
looking insane some of those clips that
i saw i'm like this man
he's looking insane plus 800 i don't i
mean i love that actually i love the
plus 800 i'm rocking with steph curry i
think the warriors are going to be a
better team this year like i said i
think he should have won the mvp last
year but you know they scratched their
way to the eighth seed and they did not
make the playoffs but uh
this year gonna be a different story and
now i'm rocking with steph curry to win
the mvp uh
gave out some hoodies already i might
want to give out another one i don't
know aaron if you ever look into the
comments you see somebody willing of a
hoodie just holler let me know and we
will get them hoodie but let's talk
rookie of the year lamello was the
favorite last year and he won the award
this year the favorite is jaylen green
let's take a look at the odds aaron what
do you see
well four of the last ten winners were
the first overall pick that season but
each of the last three winners were
either the second or third player chosen
like you said jalen green the favorite
right now plus 210 but there's good
value on some some of these other guys
meaning of jalen suggs plus 700
davion mitchell 16-1 as well as some of
these other people evan mobley up there
13-1 so this is a good market to be
betting it
it is a good market are you riding with
the favorite this year or are you
picking a dog
so i'm gonna go with the long shot
gonzaga's jalen suggs i mean suggs is
gonna be able to help orlando who has
limited death i mean again looking at
this market it's hard to bank on an mvp
because again he has to stay healthy
he's on a new team they're coming from
college a lot of things can happen but i
think again go with a long shot in this
heron is rocking with the long shot okay
okay uh
sucks he's a good pick we saw what he
did at gonzaga we'll see what he does
with this orlando team but i had a
chance aaron i had a chance to watch a
lot of these guys play in the summer
league i did and
no one impressed me like davion mitchell
in fact he led that sacramento king
summer league team to the summer league
championship and he played aggressive
out there he had that dog mentality he
hit his threes i can see that
translating into his game on that
sacramento kings team uh this year and
so i'm going with a long shot here and
i'm going with the long shot and i'm
going with my own eye test i'm rocking
with daveon mitchell to win the rookie
of the year this year
but we're not done i'm in the comments
man i gotta see who the people are
riding with uh i see a lot of kade
cunningham um
green green green sleeper sale one has a
gift with jalen green dunking on
somebody shout out to you sleeper cell
you are walking away with hoodie uh
blind
inside information
being at the league oh
oh being at the summer league i mean you
know you know you know we get around we
we get around there so we've been on the
road this summer a little bit uh do got
the little inside information
my own eye test but we'll see what
happens in the in the regular season but
you're getting love in the comments and
i got to read this one landon fuss 18
says aaron got it right aaron got it
right it sucks shout out to you lance
or walking
yeah he of course he's walking away with
a hoodie um one more i got i got one
more ryan ray
says cade cunningham shout out to you
ryan you are walking away woody i got
one more jersey to give away so it's
time for our last segment aaron it is
time for our last segment you know it
wouldn't be a group chat if i didn't
cook up
a little same game parlay but before i
kick it off fanduel has a little
something special for those of you who
like to sprinkle on the same game parlay
erin tell the audience what's up
so all fanduel customers will receive
one risk-free same game parlay to be
used tuesday wednesday or thursday you
can choose a popular same game parlay or
you can create your own either way it's
risk free so you can check out your
accounts to claim your first risk free
sgp to use on again the first three days
of this season greg let's hear your same
game pearl lag what are you cooking up
for tonight
before i get my parlay before i get my
parlay what i need everybody to do is
tell me what you think of my picks in
the comments i'm giving away a jersey to
my favorite take
aaron are you ready
i'm ready for it
all right here we go here we go let me
pull it up on my handy dandy phone um
all right we're starting it off
we talked about it earlier in the show
we talked about lebron's point total i
said he was going over and i'm gonna
continue to say he's going over tonight
so we're going with lebron james 25 plus
points lebron uh like i said he's gonna
have to put the ball in the basket we
know the lakers have a team full of
facilitators but who's going to put that
ball into the bucket and i think lebron
james is going to be one of them tonight
sticking with that game obviously we're
going to look at the first quarter total
we're going to look at the first quarter
total and it's sitting at 57 and a half
we're going to go under here the lakers
are historically known as a slow
starting team and i feel like that trend
is going to continue in today's game so
we're going to go under 57 and a half
for the first quarter total aaron
moving on to another future hall of
famer on this lakers team aaron
russell westbrook
no i'm not going to go to his assist
totals i'm gonna talk about him putting
the ball in the basket
usually when he plays steph curry he
tries to rock the baby we know that he
tries to rock the baby against steph
curry that's probably a mismatch so i
think that that's going to continue
today and i think that he's going to go
over 17 and a half points and that's an
alternate total in fact i think he's
going to score more so he's going to go
over 17 and a half uh i think russ is
gonna try to look to score a lot um
in today's game moving on to my guy
steph curry aaron moving on no i'm not
going with any points totals i'm gonna
go with steph assist numbers i'm gonna
go with
plus uh four plus assists go look for
your shooter steph the warriors added to
their team this year we do have more
shooters so go look for those shooters
you're gonna gravitate that lakers
defense and just swing that ball around
go get me four steps
and last but not least last but not
least draymond green big draymond big
draymond i'm going over seven and a half
sis like i just said the warriors have a
team full of shooters they have steph
curry
and we've gotten better around the
perimeter shooting the three draymond
pass that ball around find steph a
couple times
find other shooters and uh give me a
seven and a half plus this just give me
those seven and a half assists um
that's my parlay aaron let's pull up
those odds let's pull up those odds
let's pull up those that's why sure plus
assist
is definitely my favorite only thing i'm
talking about is just
james going over his points and same
thing with westbrook but other than that
i really like it it's a good one
2057. we go seat yeah we go we do we we
go see this it gives you 2057
if you put a hundred dollars on it so uh
we're gonna see i'm in the comments
right now let me see what they talking
in the comments about my parlay aaron um
let me see your boy landon is black your
boy landon your boy landon is back in
the comments shout out to you landon uh
jessie bolano says jesse bolano says
like hungry that mvp he's going to eat
this year um i believe he is talking
about
i believe i believe he's talking about
lebron james
shout out to you jesse just for the good
vibes just for the good vibes we're
gonna we're rocking with you i'm giving
out more um hoodies
here we go
i got damien lillard is a sleeper i got
micah says we're riding with greg paper
jesse shout out to you he says we're
riding with greg uh enderman g-money
always got the best parallels no cap
best of the best everybody that i just
said you guys are rocking walking away
with a hoodie and aaron i have to give
out a jersey here i have to give out a
jersey here um
i'm in the comments i'm looking for a
good take and i got eric mccall he says
i think lebron james scores less than 25
because westbrook
really looks to score on curry first
quarter
under the same reason you said curry
assist good dre good
too i i'm sorry i got kind of i love you
at the end
i got kind of i got kind of confused
with
yeah yeah i got kind of confused with
the comment at the end i think it was a
couple grammatical errors but that is
okay we we understood the take we
understood to take lebron james is going
less than 25 that is what you said aaron
you said under 23 and a half i see the
vibes there so eric mccall i'm going to
hook you up with a jersey i'm gonna hook
you up with a jersey aaron i think it's
time to take it on home
i think it's time to take it on home
thank you guys for tapping into the
group chat presented by fanduel remember
what you learned today the golden state
warriors and the lakers three by two is
a lot lebron might have a good game but
golden state will be ready
kb is putting up more points than
giannis
and we'll be back next week giving out
more hoodies more jerseys and more locks
and if you want a hoodie today
we will dm you not me i won't dm you
aaron won't dm you but br betting will
reach out and dmu and you know what
aaron i'm going to give out a hoodie
right now just for fun but i i got two i
got two commenters got two commenters i
want you to let me know who shot should
give the hoodie to i got greg quinn greg
greg quinn says
rick quinn says westbrook might not get
the over since he's a passer and looks
to get guys open he's referring to me
talking about his point totals over 17
and a half so we got greg quinn with
that take and then i got j23 cassettes
westbrook james mellow going off tonight
lebron james 34 points with the triple
double
whoo i don't know if i think i got to go
with the first one
the first one you're rocking with the
first one there's i don't think all
three of them go off
i don't think they possibly can
you got it quinn shout out to you
yeah yes aaron said you got to just pick
one of them hey greg quinn shout out to
you you are walking away with the hoodie
uh but make sure you guys get on fanduel
ride with us follow us on all social
media platforms alongside the lovely
aaron dolan i'm greg ivory we are
leaving the group chat peace
[Music]
you